i received a script called everything
everywhere all at once from daniel quan
and daniel scheinert so when i met them
they're quite quiet and they look kind
of harmless were they directing duo
daniels then before you know it these
two turn into some kind of crazy genius
and so i said yes
there are a million things we could say
about this movie it covers every emotion
every genre and everything everywhere
all at once all at once and yet it still
holds together because at its core it's
a family drama about a mother trying to
reconnect with her family in the middle
of all this noise it's all in their
minds their crazy warped minds that they
created this story kind of knew to
expect something just so out there
we wanted to take this kind of sci-fi
conceit of the multiverse and then take
it to absurd places but also take it to
philosophically relatable extremes so it
asks the question how do we pay
attention to the ones we love when the
universe is trying to take that
attention away from them and we asked
ourselves who would our protagonist be
and as soon as we had the idea that
maybe it would be one of our parents it
was so inspiring and it was so fun to
write a character inspired by our
parents you know and then write a
villain inspired by us
i found them very very smart and witchy
the daniels are really good with hearing
their actors thoughts or feedback is
very much a collaborative process if
you're ever around the daniels you just
sense this energy and this fun i truly
think they're soulmates they are hive
mind they are able to sometimes complete
each other's sentences every scene has
been thought out
and composed and yet allow you to play
they have created a situation where
everybody should be more friendly and
more creative there's a real feeling of
kindness it's very intentional the way
that everyone is cultivating a workspace
that is full of joy despite all of the
pyrotechnics and the fabulous cinematic
flourishing and flaring at the core it's
a love story between a mother who's
feeling that her daughter has stepped
away from her that's where i think the
daniels was so brilliant they pull the
rug from under you and we can go to
these universes where you go that's
crazy that's outrageous it's totally out
there it's not possible but
the intensity of the emotions the
sincerity of the love or confusion or
heartbreak is so tangible and so real
that you believe it it was never our
intention to
tell a story an immigrant story the
multiverse is so much about asking what
if and wondering about regrets and so
much of the immigrant story is about
taking risks and asking what if i hope
that when you see
our film you find that at the end of the
day family do come together family do
stick up for each other this has just
been it's been one of the best
adventures of my life
[Music]
you